>> SINGERS: ♪ Safelite repair,
Safelite replace. ♪
♪.
PETE: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT
TAKING THE BORDER CRISIS INTO
HIS OWN HAND.
WILL: DIRECTING STATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO START ARRESTING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FOR
TRESPASSING.
RACHEL: NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL PRESIDENT BRANDON JUDD
JOINS US TO REACT.
>> HI, RACHEL, HOW ARE YOU?
RACHEL: TELL US WHAT THIS WILL
DO.
THE STATE OF THE TEXAS WILL
ARREST PEOPLE.
WILL THIS SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
IS IT ENOUGH.
>> IT IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT.
YOU HAVE TO BE ECSTATIC A
POSITIVE IS STEPPING UP DOING
THE JOB THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS NOT DOING.
HE WILL DELIVER A CONSEQUENCE.
TAKE A PAGE OUT OF TRUMP
PLAYBOOK.
HE WILL DELIVER A CONSEQUENCE
FOR THOSE PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE EXTREMELY
UPSET THIS GOVERNOR IS DOING THE
JOB EVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION REFUSES
TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
BY GIVING THE RESOURCES TO THE
BORDER PATROL THAT IS NECESSARY
FOR TO US SECURE THE BORDER.
AS WE GO OUT AND WE PUT THE
UNIFORM ON, AS WE PATROL THE
BORDER, IF WE DON’T HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS BACKING
US UP, GIVING US THE RESOURCES
YOU WILL SEE THIS CRISIS
CONTINUE TO GET BIGGER BUT
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS STEPPING UP.
IS GOING TO HELP TEXAS BUT
LIKELY TO PUSH THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION TO STATES LIKE
NEW MEXICO, ARIZONA AND
CALIFORNIA.
RACHEL: LIKE A BALLOON.
WILL: BRANDON, PASSING IS
OBVIOUS CHARGE.
SEEMS LIKE IT WILL STICK.
IS THAT STATE AUTHORITY, A STATE
CRIME, FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY WOULDN’T MAKE TOES
ARRESTS, RIGHT?
>> IT WILL HAVE TO BE BY THE
STATE, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN’T ENFORCE STATE LAWS.
SO THE STATE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
STEP IN.
THEY WILL DO IT.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT GOVERNOR
ABBOTT IS DOING.
PETE: IS THERE CAPACITY?
DO THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
THIS?
WHEN WE SEE THE IMAGES ON THE
BORDER OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS
DEALING WITH MIGRANTS, THEY WILL
NOT BE CHARGED WITH ADDRESS
PASSING THERE, ONES THAT GET
THROUGH?
>> NO, IT WILL HAVE TO BE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
BY THE STATE.
SO THE PEOPLE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
BY THE BORDER PATROL.
THEY WILL NOT BE TURNED AROUND
CHARGED BY THE STATE.
WHEN TEXAS DPS OR WHEN A COUNTY
SHERIFF TAKES SOMEBODY CROSSING
THE BORDER I RECALL LEGALLY INTO
CUSTODY THEY CAN CHARGE THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH CRIMINAL
TRESPASSING.
IT IS A VERY GOOD STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
RACHEL: BRANDON, LET ME ASK YOU
SOMETHING ELSE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS THEY WANT TO
DO A INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THIS
HUGE TRILLION DOLLAR BILL THAT
THEY WANT TO DO, HOWEVER THEY
STOPPED CONSTRUCTION, ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS JOE BIDEN DID WHEN
HE GOT IN OFFICE, STOPPED
CONSTRUCTION OF A INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT ON THE WALL ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
HOWEVER THEY’RE STILL PAYING
$2 BILLION TO FULFILL THE
CONTRACT AND TELL PEOPLE, TELL
THOSE COMPANIES NOT TO BUILD IT?
PETE: PAYING FOR THE WALL.
RACHEL: IS THAT WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
>> TO AVOID LITIGATION THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS IN FACT PAYING
CONTRACTING COMPANIES THE MONEY
THAT THEY WERE SCHEDULED TO MAKE
BUT THEY’RE JUST NOT DOING ANY
WORK FOR IT.
SO YEAH, THEY’RE TAKING AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS MONEY AND THEY’RE JUST
GETTING ANYTHING OUT OF IT.
PETE: MORE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO
WORK.
THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
RACHEL: BY THE WAY, WE DON’T
HAVE A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER WE
DON’T NEED A WALL.
WE’RE SEEING 180,000 PEOPLE COME
EVERY MONTH.